something about a shocker at the end of
season 2 that shocked even you I can't
talk about that at all I'll get fired I
will get fired but yeah something is
about to happen which will come it
doesn't come till the very end the
season that is gonna blow people's minds
looking for you I'm just trying to see
you everybody wants to know more of we
know that Michael's with Maria right now
but will Alex find his way back into
Michael's life what can you tell us yeah
I think you know without any spoilers or
anything I think I think Michael is in a
great relationship with Maria right now
right and I think him and Alex have
actually never had a great relationship
you believed people were good despite
him and me doing everything to prove you
otherwise
and God I love you for it we'll say like
in the team and in the scheme of TV
there is something very interesting that
happens when Alex and I are on camera
together you know I feel it too
you know I like women and I like to do
it so working with him there's such a
like a tormented past that that's some
of my most fun things to play you know I
keep it pretty light in person but I've
got a lot of you know like we all do got
a lot of darkness and and feelings of
loneliness or sadness or depression or
whatever and I like I don't show that
stuff in real life so in order to get
like the fact that I get to do that on
camera and that's like my therapy almost
is really special
yeah but not like with a lead role that
represents the lgbtq+ community I mean I
can imagine your fan reaction is a
pretty positive it's unbelievable
people talking about just the Malik's
Loveline the ship and myself and Tyler
Blackburn's performances have allowed
them to feel a little bit more free to
come out to their family and face their
truth and as an actor that's what you're
always trying to do so the fact that our
truth is you know kind of encouraging
people to follow their truth and that's
like the biggest compliment you can get
as an actor